[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
Colombia en esta ocasión hablaremos
sobre los problemas de gobernabilidad
que afronta la administración de Gustavo
Petro a tan solo 7 meses de su llegada
del poder se ha enfrentado a una primera
crisis ministerial ya las distintas
dificultades para poder pasar sus
proyectos de ley en el congreso
[Música]
en el camino que se había trazado
Gustavo Petro desde que llegó a la
presidencia para aprobar una serie de
reformas al sistema de salud y en
materia laboral se ha encontrado con
muchos detractores Petro llegó con
planes de cambiar por completo el modelo
de salud pero la oposición y hasta a
partir de los aliados de gobierno
reprobaron su propuesta entre otros
argumentos por falta de debate la medida
más rechazada en el proyecto del
mandatario es que los recursos públicos
de la salud sean administrados por una
entidad pública el presidente ha tenido
que sentarse a negociar con esos
partidos que inicialmente se creía le
iban a dar todo su apoyo el analista
político Mauricio Jaramillo nos Explica
en contexto si Petro conseguirá el apoyo
requerido para sus reformas
yo creo que empezó bien con la reforma
fiscal la reforma a los tributos que era
la base para poder hacer el resto de
programas Me parece que con la reforma
la salud el discurso de la ministra fue
interpretado como radical y ahora con la
reforma laboral
la reforma las pensiones y algunas de
las reformas emblemáticas por ejemplo la
paz total la percepción que hay es que
el gobierno de Petro se ha venido
radicalizando lo cual no es del todo
cierto antes de que iniciara el actual
gobierno Petro y su coalición pacto
histórico comenzaron a hacer alianzas
con otros partidos políticos para tener
mayorías en el congreso logró tener de
su lado a los liberales algunos
conservadores y al partido verde pero no
ha sido suficiente para que los
proyectos avancen con gran velocidad en
el legislativo y ha tenido que
reformular parte de esas propuestas
tres razones que explican los problemas
de gobernabilidad de Petro el primero es
una muy grande colombiano nunca había
tenido un gobierno de izquierda y eso
hace que muchas de las demandas de las
reivindicaciones estuvieran atoradas
durante años y este gobierno pues lo van
a responsabilizar de hacerla lo segundo
es que tenía una coalición de gobierno
en el legislativo que ha sido más débil
de lo que se pensaba era una coalición
tan grande en términos de partidos que
alarga terminó desintegrándose y En
tercer lugar hemos tenido también mucha
polarización que es un fenómeno presente
en la Colombia los últimos 10 o 12 años
esa polarización desde que Petro asumió
se ha venido dramatizando a finales de
febrero Petro tuvo su primera crisis
ministerial en donde hubo un primer
rompimiento con el centro al despedir a
Alejandro Gaviria suministro de
Educación ex precandidato presidencial y
exministro de salud de la Administración
Santos junto con otros funcionarios de
otras carteras presentaron una carta en
la que expresaban sus críticas a la
reforma a la salud también despidió a la
ministra de cultura Patricia ariza una
aliada de su política social y a la
ministra de deporte María Isabel Urrutia
una medallista olímpica para Jaramillo
No es más que un remesón político en el
que el presidente está afinando el
engranaje de su gobierno yo no creo que
sea una crisis ministerial yo creo que
hubo un relevo creo que son tres casos
distintos la ministra del deporte sale
por evidentemente malos manejos Me
parece que la declaración su despido es
justificado la ministra de cultura mi
juicio es la más la más significativa
porque es romper con un sector de la
cultura que lo había acompañado desde
que era candidato y la salida del
ministro de Educación creo que obedece a
egos no teníamos un ministro que siendo
titular de la cartera de Educación
opinaba más del tema de salud
opinaban más del tema de Hacienda que de
la propia educación entonces me parece
que ahí Pues básicamente no cabían dos
autoridades en ese gabinete al inicio de
su mandato la imagen favorable del
presidente colombiano de izquierda iba
en alza pero desde los cambios de su
gabinete los números un giro en su
contra según la última encuesta de la
firma de atexco la imagen desfavorable
de Petro fue del 47% superando a su
imagen favorable de
44%, además el 50% desaprueba la forma
como está manejando el país y solo un 39
lo aprueba entre todo Gustavo Petro no
solo se encuentra en una complejidad
política Colombia también enfrenta en la
actualidad una escalada de violencia en
las regiones por parte de grupos armados
ilegales y delincuencia común su
proyecto de paz Total que busca un
acuerdo para terminar años de conflicto
no solo con la guerrilla del eln sino
con las disidencias de las FARC grupos
de narcotraficantes o bandas criminales
se encuentra en un punto crítico
el pasado 19 de marzo suspendió el alto
al fuego con el grupo narco paramilitar
clan del Golfo tras un ataque a la
policía también el presidente colombiano
se ha visto envuelto en escándalos
políticos uno de ellos El de su hijo
Nicolás Petro quien estaba afrontando
una investigación por supuestamente
haber recibido dineros en la campaña
electoral que nunca entraron en las
cuentas del pacto histórico además
habría utilizado su influencia para
pedir cargos en el gobierno a cambio de
favores sin tener un año en el gobierno
Petro Ortega una serie de dificultades y
le queda el tiempo contado para saber si
podrá llevar a cabo la propuesta de
campaña que le ofreció a más de 48
millones de colombianos en pro de
solucionar sus problemas económicos
políticos y sociales las reformas que
son su punto de lanza están jugando en
contra como también lo está haciendo la
alta inflación la volatilidad del dólar
la creciente tasa de desempleo que en
enero de 2023 fue el 13,7%, la violencia
latente y la fuerte oposición un
panorama complicado para el primer
mandatario de izquierda que tiene
Colombia en toda su historia republicana
los esperamos en otra entrega de enlace
andino siga con más información en Flash
24 y France 24.com